- Hi, everybody, and welcome to our preview of Capital One's "The Match: Champions for Change."
I'm Brian Anderson, your host, and joining us via Cisco Webex are four competitors this year.
We've got the two Hall of Famers, Phil Mickelson and Charles Barkley.
And the two future Hall of Famers, Peyton Manning and Stephen Curry.
Guys, thanks for being with us.
Looking forward to watching all of you play or maybe at least watching three of you play golf.
Coming up, November 27, Friday after Thanksgiving.
Gonna raise a lot of money, the primary beneficiary, HBCUs (historically Black colleges and universities).
And we're going to be providing a bunch of meals as well.
We're already basically nearly six million dollars into the charitable contributions.
We haven't even started yet. So this should be a lot of fun.
I want to go around the horn here, talk to everybody really quick. Phil, I want to start with you.
This is your third time around with The Match. You've been a part of all of them.
Now we're going to your home course, a place you love so much you bought.
Tell us about Stone Canyon.
Tell us about your expectations for The Match. The third version, "Champions for Change."
- As I look at Peyton, I can't help but be envious and jealous of the fact that he won the last match.
And so I took it away from his partner's home course
and brought it to a course that I own and have a little bit of knowledge and understanding on
because I want the title back.
And I upgraded my partner. I brought in Sir Charles, and I feel like we're ready to go.
And Stone Canyon is this beautiful setting that's going to be challenging for players of Steph and Peyton's skill level.
But I think Charles and I are going to be just fine on it.
- And you'll be playing for Jackson State.
Charles. My first question to you is, why on earth would you leave that cushy booth gig next to me and Trevor Immelman and want to go play golf in this scenario, man?
I mean, I thought we had a good thing going there in Florida.
- Well, let me tell you something. It’s an honor and a privilege to play with these three guys, first and foremost.
And listen, we're gonna raise a lot of money for some great charities. But, you know, BA, I got to pick a little point with you.
You said, number one, I'm blessed to be in the Hall of Fame and Phil's in the Hall of Fame.
How do you know Steph and Peyton gonna get in the Hall of Fame?
- Confident, man. Peyton's going in, in '21. I feel it in my bones.
He’s a voter.
- We don't know that yet.
- Brian’s a voter.
- It’s gonna be a nail-biter on both of those guys.
You just said they future Hall of Famers. I mean, you’re pretty presumptuous there.
- You know, that's what we do. We don't stick with the facts in my line of work.
We just kind of, we throw a lot of stuff out there, and just, you know, we make it up as we go.
Who are you playing for in the event? Charles, give us your college.
- I'm playing for Tuskegee.
You know, BA, I'm really concerned about a lot of these schools.
I've been involved with Morehouse and Clark in Atlanta. And Miles College and Alabama A&M in Birmingham.
And I just added Tuskegee to my portfolio. So I'm just excited, man.
Cuz it's a little down the street from Auburn. So I've been there many times, and I can't wait to raise a ton of money for them.
- Very cool. All right, Peyton, you're up next.
So you're the defending champ. Phil mentioned that. You're trading Tiger Woods for Stephen Curry.
Your expectation level coming in. I thought you, you played great in the last match in the driving rain.
You and Stephen are pretty formidable. You two are the favorites right now, according to DraftKings.
- Well, this would be our first time playing together.
Steph and I never played golf together, and like Phil said, he brought it to his home course
where he designed it, knows all the nuances, knows where to hit the ball.
Steph and I are not going to have a caddy, so we are going to be totally on our own the entire time.
I'm a little concerned about playing with Steph.
Steph doesn't really know what alternate shot is because he never alternates who shoots on the court.
He shoots every time. So am I going to get to play? I'm not sure. But you know what? I'm fine with that.
If he wants to hit every shot, let's do it. Our chances are probably better if he does.
But it's an honor to be back.
It's an honor to be asked by Phil and all the people that started The Match to be a part of this.
Raised 20 million dollars last time for COVID relief.
And as you said, the beneficiaries are HBCUs this year, which is a tremendous cause.
It's going to be fun to be a part of it again, to compete with Steph
and to watch Phil do his craft and to try not to watch Charles.
I think it will be a challenge for Steph and I to kind of block our vision as he's hitting.
I think mentally that's the right way to approach it.
- Peyton, tell us the three schools you're going to be playing for. Not just one. You're taking on three there in Louisiana.
- Yes, splitting some of the money raised through this match to start scholarships for a deserving student at Lane College in Tennessee,
Southern of New Orleans, SUNO, as it's known as, in New Orleans and Grambling State University.
So honored to partner with those three schools and to try to help a deserving student take a little burden off of him or her.
- That’s outstanding. All right, Stephen, you're new to the game. We're glad you're here.
Welcome to The Match family. You've been watching from afar.
What made you want to be a part of this and participate?
I think we're all excited to see how your game holds up with these other competitors.
- Oh, yeah. I was watching The Match 2, just kind of taking it all in,
you know, watching Peyton just surprise everybody with his talent out there on the course.
Phil, just trying to do whatever he could with his partner early in the round and keep him motivated.
I feel like he's going to have to do a lot of that come next Friday.
So he's got some reps. That's good.
But you know how much I love golf, competing, you know, all over the country,
just trying to play as much as I can and raise awareness of how much I love the game.
So this is a cool opportunity. I think I petitioned pretty hard sending out that tweet during The Match 2, like, “Hey, I want in,” and now we're here.
So the one thing I am, you know, a little concerned about is Phil's intimidation strategies.
I'm looking at his frame right now, and that's just ridiculous.
And I don't know if he's trying to send subliminal messages to me and Peyton or if he's...
I have a bookshelf back here, but I got nothing on it.
So, a missed opportunity. Missed opportunity.
- It needs to start early. It has to start early.
- Stephen, I know who you’re representing. You started a golf school.
Look at this. Look at what Coach [Samuel] Puryear sent me.
- Yeah that's big right there. Howard Bison.
-You're gonna play for them.
- I am. I'm playing for Howard Bison.
I was fortunate to be a part of bringing their Division I golf program back. Made that commitment last year.
And obviously with COVID everything, things got a little bit delayed,
but we're looking forward to the spring to hopefully getting them out on the course,
and starting their journey as a program.
And so we're playing for Howard, you know, Coach Puryear, who's there.
We got a lot of talented men and women golfers that are in the program.
Just try to create as many scholarships and lead towards an endowment that will keep the program around forever.
So excited to play for them and hopefully raise a lot of money.
- All right, well again, it's going to happen the Friday after Thanksgiving.
Guys just want to bounce around a little bit with format. So it's going to be modified alternate shot on 17 of the 18 holes.
There will be a scramble hole. And that's going to be interesting.
So, Phil, you've kind of developed a little bit of the style of play. Now at The Match 2, the one we did on Memorial Day,
alternate shot was on the back nine. And you and Tom had a great run, had an amazing nine holes on that alternate shot.
So maybe you tailor that a little bit to your game. You and Charles.
I'm curious to see how much desert time you're going to get with Charles on the alternate shot format.
- Well, I'm not unfamiliar with playing out of the rough, out of the desert, so that doesn't scare me off.
My partner, he knows how to play the game.
When I played with Charles first time back in the ‘90s when he was on the Phoenix Suns,
he shot in the 70s. Every round, he hit the ball solid with no issues whatsoever.
And we're gonna dig deep and bring that game back. And I think we're going to win by kind of a large margin.
So my biggest concern is more I don't want it to end too early.
Like, I don't want to close them out 6 and 5 and not make it interesting and exciting for the fans.
So we certainly are concerned about that.
But, you know, from a game standpoint, my man can putt. My man can putt.
He's got soft hands, a great touch on the greens.
And if I can get the shots around the cactus and onto the green, we're going to be in good shape.
- Charles, you got a membership there at Stone Canyon yet? I mean, how many practice rounds have you put in at this point?
- I've been there twice to practice.
Get practice rounds in. And I'm going up one more time with the great Gary McCord,
one of my neighbors in Arizona. Cannot wait to get up there again.
The guys up at Stone Canyon have been amazing. I played with Coach [Steve] Loy last week, so I'm really looking forward to it.
Man, Imma have a great time. And I will say this, if I don't play well, I'll be very disappointed.
I have hit balls for at least a minimum five hours a day, and I played every single day for the last month.
If I don't play well, I'll be—number one—I'll be disappointed. Because I don't want to let Phil down.
And listen, you know, Peyton, I just got to make sure he got my phone number. He used to text me all the time.
But since Tennessee hadn't won a game, it's been a few weeks since he texted me.
- It's been more of a mental strategy by Steph and I not to text our opponents.
We just wanted to kind of get our game faces on.
And, you know, that's kind of news to me that Charles has played, has been to Stone Canyon three times.
He hasn't played golf. He's just gone there to eat three times. They have great lunch and dinner service.
So this will be his first time playing the course in the actual match on Friday.
So I feel a little better with that.
I think the one thing that didn't go unnoticed by me—I saw Steph kind of react—
is in Phil's opening comment saying that he upgraded his partner.
Now, if I'm a certain quarterback down in Tampa, I don't know how to take that.
You know, Charles, I know he's trying to create some confidence in his partner.
But I mean, Charles, you know, in that cushy booth, rippin' on Tom.
And now I can see Tom tweeting a little bit during this match, especially if Charles finds one of those,
finds a piece of desert or a cactus that he's by. I see a certain tweet coming out of one Tom Brady.
- Tell us, Phil, a little bit about the course and where you think some of the strategy will come into play.
I know there's a couple of drivable par fours.
You guys are going to play different tees on some of the holes.
And I think, Charles, they may just place him on the green a couple of times.
Is that kind of how it's going to go down, or what's the plan for Charles on these really difficult holes?
- At Stone Canyon, we actually have Chuck Tees.
Some people refer to them as ladies tees, but I call them Chuck Tees. They're up, you know, a little bit further up.
But the course is actually pretty penalizing in spots because of the desert.
But it's also got a great mixture of fun holes like drivable par fours, reachable par fives.
Great mixture of length off the tee on the par threes.
Our sixth hole is a spectacular par three with waterfalls and such.
It's only about a wedge, but it's a very demanding shot.
I actually feel like Charles is better adept on the green on that hole.
So if I can hit the green and let him putt, that would be, that's our strategy on that.
Same thing on the drivable par fours. We saw what happened in The Match 2,
where we were really getting beat up pretty good. And then Tom and I on 11,
I drive the green and he rolls the putt in for eagle, and it just turns the whole match the other way.
And we get all the momentum. And we really should have won that match.
I mean, there were a couple of things down the stretch. I mean, Peyton's iron shot on 16 to three feet.
I don't know. I don't know if that, that was legit or not. I don't know what happened there.
I missed something. I couldn’t see the green. I couldn't see that far up the rain.
And somehow his ball is three feet from the hole. When it's all said or done, I don't know, I question that.
So I don't want to, you know, file lawsuits and try to, you know, question the outcome or any of that stuff.
But I do have a question on that one.
- Yeah. No fraud involved.
- So we are going to have spotters.
I'm gonna to have spotters from my camp, make sure that any time we have a blind shot,
we're able to see the opponent, where the ball goes, tracking them in the desert, whatnot.
But there's a great, there is a great mixture in all seriousness of spectacular clubs and shots throughout your bag.
Like, you're not going to hit the same club over and over. And certainly with Charles as my partner, I won't either.
- Stephen, I know you played with Phil in a pro-am on the PGA Tour. You've competed,
I think you competed as an amateur, but you played in what is now the Korn Ferry Tour.
I mean, you've kind of been in the fire a little bit.
And I know, Peyton, you've played in a number of pro-ams throughout your career.
So give me, Stephen, give me a little idea of your mindset going into this event.
You know, you're gonna be wearing a microphone, an earpiece.
Gonna be a lot of banter going on.
I know you can talk trash because I've heard it down on the floor.
Are you going to be able to translate that with these alpha dogs and the golf game?
- For sure.
I mean, that's the benefit of playing, you know, in front of 19,000 people every day.
You can handle noise and distractions even on the golf course.
So bringing that element of experience.
The one thing, I do have to ask about is,
you know, if there's a rules committee or board of governors or somebody that I can protest the spotters
that Phil is going to place on the course. That's like bringing your own refs to a playoff game.
I don't understand how that works. So Peyton, we got to find, you know,
some eligible candidates to put it in the field ourselves, make sure, you know, we count all the strokes.
So that's big. But I think, yeah, I'm excited.
Between me and Peyton, point guards and quarterbacks, there's a lot of chemistry
and a lot of similarities there of how we see, you know, a particular game, particular hole,
particular scenario and being able to kind of react on our feet.
So, you know, hopefully we hit a lot of good shots.
I've seen Peyton play, obviously, in The Match 2,
I know it's in there. Phil, that was not a coincidence.
That's pure skill. So I'm ready to ride that train all the way to a victory.
- Nice. Peyton, give me some thoughts about doing this again, second time around.
How you enjoyed the first one you competed in, and then now
we're here for the "Champions for Change" version of this one.
- Well, my mindset is very similar. Is to try to put Steph in the best position.
You know, when I was playing with Tiger,
trying to hit the best shot I could to give him just any chance of hitting it to the green.
And so it's kind of the same approach with Steph. I haven't played with him, but I've seen his game.
He's got all the shots, and I'm looking forward to kind of watching him do his thing.
So hopefully I can drive the ball better than I did last time.
And give him a chance to maybe to hit that second shot up there close to the hole for a little tap-in, tap-in birdie.
The weather, Phil, as promised, will be better. It will not be a monsoon this time in Arizona.
So that'll be good. I think there will be some blind shots all day
because it'll be hard to see around Charles where the ball went.
So there will be some blind shots. Let's all just admit that.
It's going to be a lot of fun. No question about that.
Look, Phil Mickelson is one of the greatest competitors of all time. I can see the look in his eyes right now.
He is focused. He is ready.
How he thinks, you know, Charles is an upgrade. You know, I’d probably question Phil's GM skills on an NFL team.
Like the Chargers this year, Brian. They're going to have a high pick in the draft. Right?
We pretty much know that. Right?
The idea is they're going to try to draft someone that's going to help them improve next year.
And so for Phil to draft Charles, I'd like to know what went into that process,
what criteria he was looking for and how he landed Charles Barkley as his draft choice.
- Go ahead, Phil.
- So that's actually an easy one to answer, because as I assess our opponents,
I find that Peyton, the thing that you do so well in golf is that you play within yourself.
Like you know your limitations in golf. You don't try to play outside you.
You hit solid shots, keep the ball in play and you advance forward.
And I noticed in The Match 2, how you didn't try to get out of your element.
And I noticed that when I played with Steph, he has a professional-caliber game.
He has all the shots, the ability to shape it each way. And we played on a tour-caliber course.
I know the quality of our opponents.
What I found, though, was, Peyton, is that the way to win is to get both of you out of your element.
And there's nobody better at that than Charles.
He knows what to say and how to say it at the right time to get you out of your element.
And I have a feeling, in fact, I know that you're going to try shots that you shouldn't.
And that's how we're going to end up winning.
We're going to have you mess up much more so than we're going to have to outperform.
- I get it. I get that now. I get that.
I think that'll be a challenge for Steph and I, not to listen and not to watch anything that Charles does.
- Yeah.
You know, Tom was very complimentary of you, Peyton.
He was very complimentary of Tiger. He was very, very nice throughout.
He didn't intimidate. He wasn't trying to intimidate, didn’t try to, like, hit crazy drives or do anything.
And so you felt very comfortable. You were relaxed, you played within yourself,
and you had a great day, and you ended up winning a close match, 1-up. Again,
I still question a couple of the shots and, you know, throughout the round, but
I know Charles is going to be, he's going to be more attacking, like a very subtle needle,
but again, at the right times. And he just knows how to get people uncomfortable.
And it's that talent that he has that is going to give us the upper hand.
- All right Charles, give you last word here. We're gonna...
Everybody can jump in, too, but I'm calling it the Chucknado.
The Chucknado is coming.
Gary McCord, Trevor Immelman, they said your game is tight.
- Peyton has been killing me today. I just can't wait till Friday cuz I'm going to play well.
Me and my partner gonna ham and egg it. We're going to play fantastic.
I want these guys to go to the golf dictionary and look up the word “dormie.”
Get used to that word dormie. So you'll probably be dormie around 14,
if we play, if we bring our A-game, if I bring my, my decent game.
You guys get used to the word. You guys gonna be dormie around 14.
Go look up what that means, dormie.
- That big word you used, "if," man.
We're not even going to be able to hear your trash talk from the Chuck Tees, though,
so it's not even going to make a difference. We’re like, “We can’t hear you way up there.
What are you even saying?”
- Awesome, man. I can't wait to get this going.
Appreciate everybody being a part of this one.
We had great fun. The last two have been outstanding.
Everybody's gonna be wearing microphones. We'll have cool technology.
And we can't wait to see you guys perform and entertain, and we're all looking forward to it.
Thanks for doing this for us. And we'll see you guys on the golf course day after Thanksgiving.
Appreciate it.
- Yes, sir.
- Thank you, thank you, thank you.